寫過國家為什麼會失敗的MIT經濟學家Darren Esquimoglu,
2024年拿下諾貝爾經濟學獎,
這幾年他研究的是AI會讓誰受益誰被丟下。
今年9月底MIT替他的新書辦了一場座談,書名問的是自由民主到底怎麼了?
主持這場對談的是Michael Stendhal,
哈佛政治哲學教授,
他的《正義》是哈佛第一門免費放上網的課,
全世界幾千萬人看過,
中文書名叫《正義》,
一場思辨之旅。
經濟學家跟哲學家坐在一起
談的是一個老問題
新技術帶來的好處
為什麼沒分到大多數人手上
AI會不會再來一次
兩個人同意的地方不少
只是走到結論的路不一樣
前半小時談美國政治的部分
先跳過
這集從Sandoe質問經濟學家的那一段開始
Sandoe先替經濟學家把話講完
新技術跟自由貿易會有贏家
也會有輸家
但贏家賺到的多到足夠補償輸家
我們現在也聽到了關於人工智能
那些經濟學家遭遇了什麼?
犯罪是犯罪的
我並不建議您是這方面的總統
但是他們遭遇了什麼?
首先,我認為
那裡有兩個分別的談判
也許是比較多的兩個分別的談判
你所提到的兩個談判
而它們在經濟經濟,
因此在經濟經濟中扮演了相當不同的角色
一是,
我認為今天也非常主導在AI的討論中
任何科技的科技進步,
因此增加了我們能夠製造產品和服務的能力
或者在經濟學家的談論中
我們的技術可能性的限制
最終會利益每個人
有些人可能會失去工作
但有更高的生產能力
有更多的工作
有更高的薪水
任何事情你做
即使首先利益
資金主義或工程師
或一個選擇群體
都會被摩擦
所以有不同的版本
摩擦的選擇
但這基本上是
是同樣的東西
這就是我和Simon Johnson
在我們之前的書《力量與進步》中
專門試圖對待
我們的影響
但是我們嘗試了
我和David Otter
和Pascual Restrepo
做過很多的工作
我也是在嘗試
做同樣的學術東西
第二個論點是
有些永遠失敗者
尤其是當你認為
在全球的環境上
尤其是在全球共產黨的環境中
但是你也提到過
有時候賺錢比較大
而會有某種方式
以賠償輸家
問題是
這從未曾發生過
這是在政治經濟中決定的
如果你經濟更好
你也會更有力
你通常不會
持續擴展
而且我們甚至沒有
並沒有正確的藝術方法
這就是David Otter的作品
例如《中國震驚》
非常強烈地描述的
是的
我覺得這份作品
對您和您的同僚很重要
但是您和您的同僚
所做的作品
是一個適合
在經濟學上
最外層的
主流的
選擇
這並不僅僅是這樣的
而這項目中的一部分
主流經濟家或許許有的經濟家都似乎拒絕了
就是贏家賺取的賠償
並不被翻譯為有效的重新分配
這更是問問
如果重新分配是一個適當的代替
Aximoglu的答案最後落在政治
錢分不下去是因為贏家也拿到了權利
Sandel想問的是再下一步
就算錢真的分下去夠不夠
幾分鐘後他回到這題
先把不平等拆成兩種
有一個深入的分別,分別是贏家和贏家,
這不同於贏家和贏家之間的分別。
贏家和贏家,
這主要與經濟差異有關,
但也與贏家認為他們的成功是他們自己做的,
因此是他們的利益,
而因此,那些被遺棄的人也必須負責他們的命運。
我在開始的時候說過,邁克爾的工作影響了我很多,
而在這些評論中,你會看到我學習了很多邁克爾的工作的三個主要領域。
第一個是你的早期工作的社區角色,
而第二個,非常與這討論的討論有關,
尤其是從利益的壓迫來看
第一個是利益壓迫的論述
成功和失敗
可以作為虛弱的力量
對於不做的那些人
第三個是
非常有趣的方式
來承認很多的想法
我曾經困難的
就是貢獻正義的概念
就是不夠
只要重新分配
並給人們足夠的消耗
他們也需要一個認識
他們對社會的貢獻
對自己的貢獻
和其他人的貢獻
相互的認識
所有這些都相互相連
接下來他換回經濟學家的講法
拿歷史跟數字說同一件事
這不僅僅是一項重複項目
還有兩個方法
我可以再加強
第一個
我不認識任何
是根據價值增長,而不是基於價值增長。
價值增長對共產黨的共產黨和共產黨的共產黨和共產黨的共產黨的共產黨是非常重要的。
我認為我們最好可以理解
在全球基本收入的環境中
如果我們要去全球基本收入
來支持50%、60%、70%的人
在AI的時代
無法找到職業
或無法找到充足的職業
來支持上升的目標
這將會成為一個非常
他說還不必走到那一步
他跟兩位MIT同事提過一個方向
叫對勞工友善的AI
讓水電工護理師老師靠AI
做到以前做不到的事
Sando下面說的
你們三位指的就是這三個人
我認為你們三個提到的東西是非常重要的
共同富裕不僅僅是通過全球基本收入來做到的基本費用
而是實際上是參與者,有聲音,有說明
在形成我們生活的力量,包括經濟形成的形狀,以及工作的形狀。
我認為你所做的工作很重要的原因是,
在教我們AI的目標,
AI的目標,
可以增加,因此他們的薪金增加。
您提到的貢獻正義的概念,
在此背景中。
它建議的是,
貢獻正義獨自失去的,
就是我們的基礎需要,
人類基礎需要,
除了得到基本的消費物
和生活需求外,
最基礎的需要是我們同仁的需要
並且能夠使用我們的努力和才能
達到這些需要
並且獲得社會尊重、尊敬、
尊敬和認可
這就是貢獻的正義
requires beyond
what a universal basic income
might provide
and that's what makes
it's not just the money that's shared
it's the activity
it's the common life
it's the project
including the democratic deliberation
about the shape of the project
接著講回AI
業界每天說AI會改變
你生活的每一個面向
同時又叫你別擋路
交給專家跟幾家前沿實驗室就好
他說在民主社會這兩句話再矛盾不過
在一年之內被淹沒
為什麼
我希望當我來到這裡
我能從你身上學習
為什麼
不要這麼有信心
我認為
我非常擔心這些證據
並不是因為
我是一個技術專家
知道他們實際上詳細詳細詳細
證明了危機
和淹沒的可能性
而是因為
因為當這些研究室的領袖或參與者向我們宣佈我們有這麼厲害的東西,
這可能會破壞人類。
我們必須擔心這一點。
為什麼我認為這意味著懷疑?
我的看法是,
我沒有任何特殊的能力在心裡讀取高層和中層的人的意見。
但我的看法是,他們很誠實,他們很擔心這些事情。
但這也提示了,
如果你看看背景,
為何人們來自非常窄的背景,
在這種環境中受到激勵的
可能是有問題的
所有的高層層
有很多在開放智慧
有很多在深入思想
他們來自同一種環境
他們用同一種智慧
他們用同一種科學劇
他們讀同一種網絡哲學
好的
現在我們來到
一個非常重要的
理論組織
這是一個非常重要的
開放提問之後
臺下有人問
在大科技公司裡
要怎麼真的把AI
往對勞工友善的方向做
Sando是這樣回答的
我們僅僅在過去幾個月內討論了一個公開討論,
關於AI的管治。
我認為這並不足以單純設立一個管制組織,
因為這就代表了存在的組織,
並且有政府管制者從外部執行。
在AI發展的方向中,
一種方式是將公眾投入公司,
無論是通過公司的投資,
公司的擁有,
或是這些公司的偏僻公司的公司的公司擁有。
這種情況可以被作為一個例子
以此事實來說,他們所執行的大量數據
以及從哪裡來得到價值
並且從那裡進入他們在建造的擔憂的數據中
在第一個位置,那些數據是誰的?
並非他們的,有些法律組織有關特別的負債者
但除了這些法律組織有關負債者
講到發錢夠不夠
經濟學家跟哲學家
從兩條路走到同一個答案
不夠
人要有事做
也要被需要
兩個人看法不同的
只有末日論
Sando覺得那聽起來很自立
Esmoglu則相信他們是真心的
只是整群人讀的是同一批書
原影片一個多小時
問答時間AC Mogulu還講到
這幾年大科技公司的決策權
一直往最高層集中
中層工程師幾年前還有的影響力
現在沒了
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多